28 countries hello ah we've got eight
countries that are about to possibly
leave the European Union and we've got
still the eurozone crisis lying
underneath hey I'm trees about to leave
yeah we've got Spain we've got Cyprus
they're in danger of leaving there's a
chance that they will leave soon we've
got the eurozone debt crisis still
underneath the surface and we've got
thirty percent government bonds European
government bonds trading at negative
interest rates and Germany the heart of
the EU seventy percent of its government
bonds are trading at negative interest
rates I want to know how bad does it
have to get before you would think
perhaps now we should leave look I I I
don't by the way think eight countries
will leave I'm possibility well
everything is a possibility but it's but
I don't actually don't think it's going
to happen i'll tell you why because in a
globalised world where we have big
borderless threats like climate change
you know human traffickers and crime
which cross borders we have these
massive corporations that sort of you
know go from one continent to the other
you've got capital flows going from one
you know a corner of the planet to the
next it makes sense i think we've become
stronger when we do things together i
just think we can fight crime we can
fight climate change we can regulate big
global corporations better when we do it
together by the way it's a very similar
argument to what I so passionately
believe in the country the United
Kingdom that I love so much and I don't
want to see it pulled apart because I
think we are just quite simply stronger
when we do things together rather than
when we fall apart and it still isn't an
answer to my question which was how bad
would it have to get for example if
Greece was to it was to leave the
European Union and then if France which
looks set to possibly avoid oh I'm sorry
I until ana torres could possibly vote
in the Euroskeptic National Front they
did already would pull out yeah then and
get more and more complete like I don't
have the hell of discussion that does it
have to do that is that other
circumstances in which you would say
britain since I think those
circumstances are not remotely going to
happen I cannot envisage circumstances
where I think it is sensible for United
Kingdom to leave what is the world's
largest borderless marketplace of 500
million shoppers who buy our
manufactured products our services are
good do you really think
Japanese car manufacturers big
investment banks big legal firms big you
know aerospace firms would invest in our
country if we were sort of bobbing along
somewhere in the mid-atlantic friendless
unable to sell into our own European
neighborhood of course not jobs are it's
nice to be you're all right we've heard
your point thank you very much sorry not
to